Yeah, go ahead.
I just wanted to get clean audio on you saying
no boners in sight.
That was all I wanted, Brian.
How could Loki affect phase four?
How could it not affect phase four, Brian?
That's my question.
I don't know.
I'm excited to find out.
It seems clear that right now Marvel's really
leaning into the whole multi-verse thing so
that's going to be fascinating to watch and
see how long audiences want to keep watching
that happen over and over again.
I don't know.
Things have gotten-
I'm interested to find out.
-extremely weird in a very short span of time.
Yeah.
Just where the introduction of the multi-verse
in Loki was just kind of like, okay, this
is happening now and everyone seems to be
on board.
Everyone's just like, "Okay, multi-verse.
Alligator.
Got it.
Yes.
Next."
And it's pretty interesting, and it'll be
interesting to see how long they are able
to maintain that interest in a very-
Wasn't it a crocodile?
Crocodile?
Was it an alligator? I don't know.
It was an alligator, Nina.
It was some kind of-
I thought people were calling him Croki, like
crocodile Loki?
I mean, they were, that doesn't necessarily
mean that they're right.
That's true.
It's not like there's a lot of zoologists
in the MCU probably.
Right?
Don't turtles technically have fins and tortoises
have feet?
I don't know.
I don't know anything about anything in the
animal kingdom.
I think they're thinking of flippers, Brian,
you're thinking of flippers.
What did I say?
Fins?
Just before the turtle gang goes crazy in
the comment section.
Let me tell you all.
The turtle stans, yeah.
You know what I meant.
Be careful.
We've been doing this for literally two minutes
and we're already extremely off topic.
Arguing about turtles.
Just like every other episode.
How do we think it's going to affect the MCU
specifically, Tom?
So, like I said, I'm interested to see how
long we want to put up with, not put up with,
how long it's going to stay enjoyable before
people get bored with it?
Because it sounds like there are, we have
at least three projects coming up that are
based pretty firmly in the multi-verse from
what anybody can tell?
We have Dr. Strange in the Multi-Verse of
Madness, that's the title.
Kind of gives the game away.
Then you've got the new Spider-Man movie that
I feel like everybody like tried to keep it
very quiet then Alfred Molina showed up.
He was like, "Oh yeah, I'm doing it.
I'm back.
Great to be back in the arms after 20 years.
Good to see everybody."
And then Ant-Man 3, Quantumania.
Which we know Kang will be in.
Right.
Because that was when they first announced
the amazing Jonathan Majors, who I loved in
the Loki finale, he was perfect, will be a
part of the film.
And that's the other thing that I'm really
interested to see what they do with it because
Kang as a character in the comics never really
did anything for me, not my all-time favorite.
He always just seemed too convoluted and stupid,
I said it, I don't care.
Kang the Conqueror was stupid.
I mean, knowing what you know about Kang,
and we'll try to fill in the blanks for each
other, what can you tell us about the origins
of Kang the Conqueror as a character?
I would be happy to.
Okay.
We begin our story in the 31st century, a
young man named Nathaniel Richards gets bored
and decides that he wants to stop living in
a futuristic utopia and instead go be a Pharaoh
for awhile.
So he time travels.
He time travels right back to-
So relatable.
Yeah.
We've all been there.
If I had a nickel.
Quarantine had a lot of us kind of exploring
our options.
So he does that.
He gets beat up for awhile.
After that, it gets kind of fuzzy.
He travels back into the future.
He meets a girl.
He can't take over the 20th century because
there are too many Hulks and Ironmen.
He tries to impress a girl by, by beating
up the Avengers.
The girl dies.
Then there are a ton of different multi-versal
Kangs and time-travel
Kings and all of these.
I was just never on board with whatever his
master plan was.
He's like a confusing, time traveling Dr.
Doom.
Very much.
Yeah.
Just minus like a lot of the super powers.
Right.
And the cool name.
Kang the Conqueror, just not a great name.
No.
That being said, Thanos, I was never super
stoked for him in the comics either and then
they turned him into this really compelling
character and it kind of looks like what they're
doing with Kang and I hope they pull it off.
Yeah.
Nina, you, you mentioned something about how
good you thought Jonathan Majors was in the
Loki finale.
Yeah.
I agree.
Do you want to tell us what you thought generally
about that performance and what you think
it promises for the future of the MCU?
Well, now that I know that Kang is maybe not
the greatest comic book character, according
to one Tom.
One Tom.
A singular Tom.
Me too.
I'll throw in-
One white man in his 30s.
No, but now that I know that he's maybe not
the most attention grabbing villain I think
it's perfect to cast a really, really compelling
actor like Majors.
I mean, the finale aired one day after he
got his Emmy nomination for Lovecraft Country,
which was canceled.
Very weird move, but he really lights up the
screen in everything that he does.
He's definitely an actor to watch.
And I mean, with the right casting and the
right writing and working with directors like,
Peyton Reed will be doing the third Ant-Man
and all of these people who we know are really...
Do we know who's directing Dr. Strange 2?
It is slipping my mind.
Sam Raimi.
That's right! So, yeah.
He's got Sam Raimi. Thank you.
So yeah, he's going to work with Sam Raimi.
I have every faith that he's going to be,
he's got a great creative team behind him
and I also think that Majors is going to keep
bringing it in his performance.
Because I just loved like the, "Really?
Who cares," attitude he brought to the character.
I love when there's like a super high-stakes
situation, the person's like, "Oh, whatever."
He was having a really good time.
He was having a great time.
He chewed every piece of scenery into shreds.
I loved it.
And I just think that's the right attitude
for a Marvel villain.
I mean, that's why Kathryn Hahn was so good.
That's why Cate Blanchett was so good in Thor
Ragnarok.
Chew the scenery and really give it 150% and
you're going to be a good Marvel villain.
So I think he's going to be great.
And just from an acting perspective, I think
that it could be a really cool part to play.
Yeah.
From what they've given us so far, like there
are going to be these infinite different variations
of a character.
Yes.
So it could be a great-
So he's going to have a lot of stuff to do.
Yeah.
This really cool showcase for his talents.
Yeah, absolutely.
That'll be neat to watch, I hope.
That was what I was going to say in terms
of you're going to get Kang in Ant-Man and
The Wasp Quantumania, and we're going to see
one interpretation of this character.
And then we're going to get probably again
in Dr. Strange in the Multi-verse of Madness
or one is first and then the other comes later,
I don't quite remember the order, but there's
a potential to see this character in every
one of these movies in some form or another,
like an end of movie stinger.
And you're not going to know which version
you're seeing, you know what I mean?
Right.
That's what's so potentially exciting about
it, which is will he be four or five different
Kangs in Ant-Man?
Right.
I don't know, but he might be six or seven
or eight in all the other movies, too.
And with an actor who, in this he was very
funny, and he's really serious in Lovecraft
Country, but somebody who can play both sides
of the coin, I think the role's in very good
hands.
Yeah.
I think it's going to be really cool.
And I'm excited that they didn't take that
long to give us our new Thanos.
When Thanos first got teased in the original
Marvel movies, the first Avengers was when
we first saw him, obviously everyone, all
fans were like, "Oh, Thanos is coming.
I know Thanos.
I recognize him."
But as Tom was saying, it's not as though,
with some exceptions, I'm sure most people
don't think of Thanos and go, "Oh, I really
like how he, you know?"
He's just a big purple guy.
Great, big, strong purple guy.
Doesn't like people around.
He likes having a shiny glove.
Yeah.
He's in love with death.
That was his big thing.
He's very into equity, but that gets overlooked.
Yeah.
Anyway, what I like about it was they set
it up in a way that left a lot to your imagination.
And then once they figured it out, they started
going in that direction.
Yeah.
But here I feel like they've got it figured
out from the outset.
So Kang is a particular kind of guy in a particular
kind of way.
And even though we're going to see different
versions of him, probably, in all these different
movies and shows, I feel like they're starting
off on really solid footing.
That has me really excited.
Well.
And to piggyback off of that, in terms of
how it's going to affect phase four, I think
everybody was like, "What is going to be the
next crossover thing now there's not more
Avengers?
Exactly.
That's going to bring everybody together and
create a multi-movie conflict, even with letting
some things stand alone because as we discussed
today, looking over the phase four list, some
things you're like, "Kang will be in that.
This will have to do with this story."
And then other things you're like, "Probably
not.
That's probably not going to be related."
I had a thought about that.
I have a thought about how they're going to
incorporate Kang and the multi-verse into
all these movies that wouldn't seemingly have
anything to do with it, like-
Is it Photoshop?
-Shang-Chi.
Well, you're not too far off.
You know how sometimes in a movie you'll be
filming one thing and then there's a guy in
the background and then they cut to someone
else and then they cut back and the guy's
gone.
Or there's different paths.
And you think they're just going to put Kang
in the background of everything?
I mean, something like that.
I think they might start to introduce some
interesting continuity errors that are-
Oh!
-a bit more noticeable.
That is cool, actually.
And people will be like, "Oh, look at this
mistake.
Look at that mistake."
And then in one in one of these movies you're
going to have like this flashback.
So all the times things were subtly changing
and that's characters hopping dimensions,
hopping timelines.
I never watched any of these shows because
I enjoy sleeping at night, but I've written
about enough of them, The like Haunting of
Hill house, Haunting of Bly Manor, all the
ghost hunting people did and the frames where
it was like there was a ghost in almost every
frame of the show or something.
That's awesome.
And people had to keep finding them.
Again, I would rather pluck my eyes from my
skull than watch that.
No offense.
I'm such a wimp.
None taken.
I can't do it.
I just can't.
I would never sleep.
No one's asking you to.
It's okay.
Don't pluck your eyes out.
Fine!
I work for a pop culture website.
I feel pressure.
It's okay.
It's all right.
I think you're onto something really cool
there though, that intentional errors will
end up forming the backbone.
I kind of love that.
Continuity errors.
I hope they do that because that'll be a funny-
Like one scene In No Way Home, Ned will be
there wearing a Hawaiian shirt that's blue
and then they'll cut to Peter Parker and then
they'll cut back and he's wearing a Hawaiian
shirt that's red, and no one will say anything,
And we'll all just be like, "Huh?
What?"
And it'll be little things.
And then as time goes on, this is in my head,
this is what's going to happen.
I love it.
So that's how I think it could affect everything.
Tom looks really excited about this.
You know what I would love so much.
I like this idea a lot.
I would love it even more if they did exactly
what you're talking about and then just never
paid it off.
Yeah, sure.
If they spent like the next two years like
getting in the head of every pedantic nerd
who watches an MCU movie-
So you want them to-
I would be right there with you.
You want them to take this concept and just
Ralph Bohner it?
Yeah.
I was just thinking that.
I don't even want them to Ralph Bohner it.
I want it to feel very much like there might
be a payoff and then they just drop it completely.
There's nothing at all.
You're a sadist.
Wow.
It's just for a couple of years, there are
these egregious errors in these movies.
Spider-Man's not wearing the same suit as
he was in the last scene.
He's played by a different actor, maybe.
Swap out Tom Holland for someone else.
I mean, that looks like it's probably going
to happen in one way or another where we're
going to get-
Right, right.
We're going to get Tobey Maguire.
I mean from shot to shot, like literally in
one scene, just like put Andrew Garfield in
and then cut back and then it's Tom Holland
again and never talk about it.
Beautiful.
Hire Robert Downey Jr. to be an extra, in
the background of a shot and just watch the
world set itself on fire.
Pay him like $5 million to be in the background
of a coffee shop.
Absolutely.
If I had Marvel money and I was making these
movies that would be the first thing I would
do.
Are you sure you want to admit that you would
just troll Marvel fans?
Are you sure that's where you want to take
this?
Absolutely.
I would troll any fans.
I fear for the comments section on this video.
Before the last Harry Potter book came out,
I thought it would have been great if Peeves
the Poltergeist wound up being like the central
character to the whole thing, just to watch
like the movies have to spin their wheels
really hard.
I think there's a lot to this.
I'm also very-
So you love chaos, Tom.
I mean a little bit.
You thrive on it.
Yeah.
It's fun to watch.
One thing I read earlier today that I thought
was interesting was that Kang is actually
the first character that the MCI has officially
brought in that was formerly owned by Fox
that they couldn't use.
Yes.
Oh.
Did you read that on a website called looper.com,
Brian?
I'm going to say yes, even though the answer's
technically no.
I'm not familiar.
I did read it though.
I mean, it's interesting.
I mean, it's definitely news.
Yeah, it's really interesting.
Yeah.
What's cool about it is he was formerly a
Fantastic Four villain because, well, he's
been an Avengers villain as well, but his
identity is Nathaniel Richards and there's
obviously, in continuity he is known to be
a descendant of Reed Richards.
Right.
Maybe.
Well, potentially.
And so he's definitely pestered the Fantastic
Four in the past.
And so what's cool here, too, is that obviously
you've got this multi-verse opening up.
It's happened.
It's happening.
And that easily opens up the door for finally,
Deadpool, X-Men, Fantastic Four, which we
know is coming.
So this is really finally the official start.
I know we all thought in WandaVision that
once Quicksilver showed up, "Oh, here it is
multi-verse."
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then Bohner.
And then, no.
But here, no Bohner's in sight.
Still not okay with it.
See, that's so funny because I thought it
was funny.
I was like ha-ha.
All the fan theories didn't pay off.
I had like a hearty little witch cackle over
it.
I laughed about it.
That was your Robert Downey, Jr. as an extra.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, cool.
And I'm 12.
So I was like, ha, Bohner.
I just laughed at it.
I thought it was funny.
And I liked Evan Peters, so I don't really-
Can we go back and-
I enjoyed it.
I hope they bring him back.
-real quick?
Yeah, go ahead.
I just wanted to get clean audio on you saying
no boners in sight.
That was all I wanted Brian.
What I was going to say is that, I mean, as
good as that joke is, the downside is that
we don't get to see Evan Peters as Quicksilver
anymore.
Now they cannot do that because it's been-
If they did it would-
Oh, they can do what they want.
They could.
I mean, we've got a multi-verse now.
We've got infinite earths.
This franchise started out being about a guy
with metal clothes and now we've got witch
hunt era sorcerers and the Eternals are about
to pop-up, if anybody can explain those succinctly,
I will happily cede my job to them.
Yeah.
I'm just saying-
Succinctly being the key.
-the door's open.
The door is open.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single video.